even if you have the best connections in
the world that's not going to make
someone write a story about a company
that doesn't have an engaging story
you have to find a way to tell the story
in a way that's engaging in a way that's
relevant for
the publication you want to be in and
tailor it tailor it to the writer
tailor it to the publication make sure
you know anyone that's doing pr that's
working in comms you have
goals you have needs a writer has those
goals and needs as well they're
different so you have to make sure that
whatever you're trying to pitch to them
is aligned with what they're trying to
achieve as well
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and
in media partnership with ctec corporate
communication
pr it's kind of a black box for a lot of
people in the tech industry
today i'm gonna try to understand it a
little bit better
meet danielle blumenstick peterman head
of corporate communications at appslier
danielle is the head of corporate
communications at b2b sas unicorn apps
flyer
as seasoned coms pro danielle has spent
the past 10 years helping brands shine
working with leading tech companies and
organizations to perfectly craft and
effectively communicate their messages
prior to apps flyer danielle spent
several years honing her comms craft as
a tech focused pr agency before devoting
her life to tech
she started her career managing pr and
investor relations for non-profit
organizations and higher education
institutions
danielle blumenstick peterman how are
you
i am great michael thank you welcome to
20 minute leaders i'm especially excited
for this episode because a lot of the
times i talk to a lot of really techy
people
really about their tech and and what i'm
excited now is to you know
move on to a different part of the
ecosystem which is
just as important which is how you know
information gets
you know shared from companies to the
outside world
you have extensive experience both in
spokesperson
arrangements assistant to the
spokesperson at the idc director of
media relations at the university of the
people
a pr supervisor at blonde 2.0
and today head of corporate
communications for apps flyer
and so it sounds like a fascinating
journey all around
moving from these different endeavors
from you know academic institutions to
pr agency now to an an incredible hyper
growth company in israel but i'll let
you tell me a little bit from your
perspective
how do you see your own journey in the
communications
space so
i think that's an interesting question
um i got to communications very randomly
i did study communications and
international relations at university so
it seemed like a natural step but when i
first graduated my bachelor's degree i
thought i was going to save the world so
i really thought that i would be working
in
peace education that was something i was
very passionate about and i thought that
would be my
career and then very early on i was
working
for a nonprofit organization called
peacenow and i kind of got acquainted
with the entire world of
pr communications working with press
working on messaging
uh and i fell in love and it was really
kind of i didn't even think of that as a
possible career path i was like oh this
is something people do for a living
that's awesome
so um and then i basically started kind
of like growing into that i managed
to get when i got into the master's
program at idc
i was able to get a position a student's
position there is the assistance of the
spokesperson
she was an incredible mentor taught me a
lot that i didn't know about the
industry
and that kind of led the way into the
position at university of the people
which is an incredible
uh not-for-profit university completely
online for people to be able to have
access to higher education
and slowly but surely i also learned you
know israel startup nation
everything at the end of the day comes
back to tech that's how i came to know
blond 2.0 i was very lucky to join there
first as a junior pr person because even
though i did have experience in the pr
it was all very focused on education on
non-profits on that world and tech is an
entirely different way of thinking
so that was really interesting and i it
was the best school i ever had better
than any of the
of the degrees that i have which i say
are great ornaments but they don't
really serve much function
and that's how i got here started apps
why i've been here almost four years now
started uh started at the bottom and now
i'm on top as they say um they don't
really start at the bottom there's no
there's no bottom at abs flyer
so yeah so
i started here i actually got here not
in a comms position i was in a place in
my career where i thought that i
need to learn a little bit more about
marketing all i've been ever doing is
comms
so i came here for a content marketing
manager position
and very quickly i kind of learned that
my love is with coms and i missed it so
much and i was very lucky there was an
open position
for a communications manager that they
actually had open in san francisco
but at the same time as i was having
second thoughts about oh maybe
communications is where my desires truly
lie
um i was very fortunate our cmo rana
verhami came up to me and he said
i think you should take that comms
position and do it here
so it's kind of like a sign from the
gods and
that's how my comscore continued i
thought it was going to take a little
hiatus but it just kept on going and
it's been uh
a train only going up roller coaster
enough so it's been really good so i'll
get to apps flyer in a second but first
i i saw one of your pieces on linkedin
about pr agencies and and
some of the you know not misconceptions
but some of the struggles and challenges
that
the industry may have with pr agencies
you know what they represent what they
actually do and the and the
you know the displacement and in you
from theory to practice
what what is it in your eyes about pr
agencies why why are they part of the
ecosystem
and how should we as you know perhaps
you know tech
founders or entrepreneurs think about pr
agencies
agencies get a bad rep because a lot of
times
it's this feeling that they're trying to
a lot of people have a conception that
they're trying to screw you over somehow
they're trying to take your money and
not do good work
um and i think that's something that
happens when people have a bad
experience with a bad vendor or they
hear about a bad experience and then
that becomes kind of like the discussion
that goes on
and cmos and ceos love saying oh i hate
pr agencies they're the worst and i
think
that's really just a huge misconception
because if you find the right partner a
pr
pr agency can take you to the stars
truly
it's all about several things about
setting the right goals
it's about making sure that the goals
are feasible because a startup that's
just started that has maybe a founder
and two employees
no money raised yet and no interesting
tory
story to tell isn't going to get on the
wall street journal
everything has to be the expectations
have to be set up in a
in a way that's kind of like makes sense
um
goals have to be set in a way that makes
sense and also what i think is super
important is
talk to the people in the in the
ecosystem this is true for any tech
ecosystem
but especially here in israel where it's
so so small people can re you can very
easily find references and find out if
people
in your industry in your scale have been
able to get good results with that
partner
so talking to people is the number one
thing um and the results you can get are
incredible because if you have a
good pr agency that's like hand in hand
with you in the trenches thinking about
good ideas
pushing you to do it better pushing you
to tell your story better
you could really get results that are
incredible and you can get results that
would be very hard for you to get on
your own which is true for any size
company a lot of people sometimes think
i'm too small to start doing pr i'm
going to wait until i have
a lot of money a lot of employees
something like that but sometimes you
need that partner to get there
and sometimes you can get um you can
work with a pr agency for
a fee that works for you and works for
your goals and helps get your name out
there
helps get your brand out there so you
can get more investors
more employees more visibility
it's a it's a chicken and egg game you
can't just one day start doing pr you
have to work on it from the beginning
i was just about to i was just about to
give that metaphor but
the you know i'm looking so what i'm
hearing from you is that that part of
this secret sauce is here is the
engagement of the pr agency it's not
just an executor
that has connections in in the various
magazines and whatever but it's also
somebody who really
understands your story understands the
you know journalism
ecosystem and then does that integration
how to modify or translate your story
into their language
and that is where the magic happens
right 100
connections aren't enough and there's a
lot of discussion about that in the
professional communications agencies
even if you have the best connections in
the world that's not going to make
someone write a story about a company
that doesn't have an engaging story
you have to find a way to tell the story
in a way that's engaging in a way that's
relevant for
the publication you want to be in and
tailor it tailor it to the writer tailor
it to the publication
make sure you know anyone that's doing
pr that's working in comms you have
goals you have needs a writer has those
goals and needs as well they're
different so you have to make sure that
whatever you're trying to pitch to them
is aligned with what
they're trying to achieve as well as
long as it's a collaboration both sides
can benefit that's a great way to
you know get the best results all around
right so now i think you were
transitioning more to apps flyer
and now your your head of of corporate
communications for apps why what does
that actually mean
the head of corporate communication what
does that work
we have a very interesting uh structure
here at
appsflyer when i first started app store
we were doing all communications
globally
here from our headquarters in israel
which was very
interesting but also very very difficult
it's incredibly challenging to do
communications
for for example china the greater china
region for aipac
for the many many markets we serve in
europe for the us
from here it's doable and we did it well
for a very long time
but it's not scalable at the end of the
day if you want to be a truly global
company
localization is key and having those
people that understand the local markets
better who can kind of go the extra mile
to understand the customers to
to tailor say ties into what i was
saying before tailor everything to
the right reporters to make those good
connections they are important they're
not enough but they are important
um we didn't have that and we kind of
grew that two years ago so basically
we shifted from a comm from a
communications organization that was two
people in israel to a communications
organization that is now
six people globally six going on seven
people globally
um and we have regional communications
managers
in north america cpac and emea
who kind of do that regional work in
their regions growing everything that
we're doing in those markets
so what does corporate communications do
anything that's global anything that has
to do with our global messaging
um global announcements about new
products new content that we're putting
out
making sure that our messaging is
aligned across markets making sure that
we give the regions
a lot of material to work with so that
they can then take that to the next
level and make sure that everyone in the
that
that they can serve the needs of their
region accordingly so they tweak
things you know some people think about
localization and think about language
it's a lot more than language it's
language it's culture it's taking
everything to the next level it's making
sure
that your region is getting everything
that it needs and make sure that it
knows also what to ask for from us in
corporate so we can kind of serve them
and give them more of what they need
to get better results all around and
it's increased our results incredibly i
mean we
we thought we were doing well and then
now that we've been having our regional
communications managers
we know that we're doing a lot better
than we were in the past
and how do you actually measure that how
do you decide on you know what is a good
kpi
for for communications how how how do we
know that we're actually doing
a good job and how do we know you know
where we could potentially get to
because you know when i'm building a
product i can say well i have
x users and i want to get to y users and
so that's
you know that's the my my mode of
improvement how do how can you
think through that mode of improvement
in your world
it's not easy and i can tell you that's
something that communications
uh professionals are struggling with
globally both in tech
and outside of tech but in tech we're so
used to measuring everything
that it's like oh brand how do i measure
the impact of my brand
it's like you know dust in the wind how
do i know how much of it i have
so we're actually trying something new
this year which is
still a little bit in the experiment
phase but we created this thing we
called our we call our brand score
which has a bunch of different metrics
some of them have to do
with website visits some of them have to
do with social media engagement some of
them have to do with press coverage
and we created this it's currently an
excel sheet that has all
kinds of bi and analysts helping us make
it into voodoo magic that turns it into
actual numbers
um but we're we've been trying it out
for
i think this is the fifth quarter now to
see if we're able to accurately measure
things
and it's interesting because we see we
did a couple of things we defined
specific metrics so i can't get into all
of it but in social media for example we
wanted to see the growth on our linkedin
we chose that specific channel on social
media to measure
growth and engagement for
press coverage we defined specific
top-tier publications in specific
markets and we decided that those are
the ones we're measuring
we don't care about general coverage we
care about
these between 10 to 20 depending on the
market publications we want to see how
we're doing
and how we're doing in comparison to our
competitors
so that's what we're measuring and it's
very interesting to see because that
also helps focus once we better define
measurement we know what we want to
focus on we know where we're focusing
our efforts
um it's been very helpful and it's
really interesting and it's something
that
um it's the the organization is really
kind of looking to hear from us quarter
over quarter like
what are we seeing in the brand score
what's changed how is it improving and
also a lot of my peers in the
communications world are eager to hear
more about what we're seeing in this
measurement so it's a little early for
me to say if it's
100 working but it is very interesting
and it definitely helped focus us which
is
something that's exciting for me you
mentioned focus about three times now
and i was just about to to allude to
that because what it sounds to me
from what you're saying is that you know
there's a lot of
there's a in communications or in
branding you know
you could have a lot of different
publications publishing you can do a lot
of noise on social media but at the end
what it sounds
like is that there are these few high
value events that happen to a brand
and then a really long tale of really
small events that don't really amount
too much
or don't really get the communication
out to the right people and i and
you know as a you know young
entrepreneur i can see okay somebody
has gotten five you know mediocre
publications that people
don't necessarily really follow and
they're doing a really great job on pr
but maybe
you know from your perspective you say
yes but are we actually understanding
the impact that they're bringing
and perhaps one big account or one big
event
trumps all those five and that's where
our focus should be right
yeah exactly so that's one of the things
that we've really been trying to focus
on because
i can tell you from our perspective
we've been seeing um
there are certain cover publications
where it's easier for us to get into
but we weren't necessarily getting the
right eyeballs on them
at the end of the day it's it's it's the
same thing as it is everywhere
quality over quantity and you just have
to not be tempted by the quantity and
focus on the quality because the quality
doesn't matter how good it looks and you
know it's very and that's another thing
that sometimes why people don't like pr
agencies because
it's easy to kind of show look at all
the coverage and it's like i don't care
about all this coverage if it's
25 000 mentions and websites that nobody
reads that's not helpful for me
but three mentions and publications that
all of my customers are reading every
day
beautiful magic so it's it's
it's hard because it's hard as a as a
marketing person
to to focus on quality over quantity
when everybody wants to see metrics
everybody wants to see growth but when
you educate both internally
and externally always quality over
quantity
and to measure the quality um it helps
it helps
again sorry to repeat myself but it
helps focus both
me and my team and also you know
leadership as well
right and so you've gotten to work in a
broad spectrum of of you know
industries and types of communications
and mediums of communication
what are then what really excites you
what really gets you going about
you know either your day to day right
now or in general
about your place in the ecosystem that
we have around us
so this is a really fascinating time
actually in uh
in the marketing measurement and
marketing technology ecosystem because
there are a lot of changes going on
there's a lot
of kind of new regulations when it comes
to privacy
and that's something it's funny we were
just talking about it the other day in
the communications team things that
scare other people
are super exciting to communications
people because it's a very exciting
challenge to get
to educate a market to get to tell a
story that's
interesting because it's different it's
not what everybody's saying you're
telling a different story you're helping
to kind of
lead people in the right direction and
it's very hard and it's very intense and
especially in a time of constant changes
it's something that you know can be a
little overwhelming at times because
it's a little bit around the clock but
it's so fun
it's just so fun to be in the thick of
it to be like there's exciting changes
happening and we are the people that
have to explain to the market what's
happening
we're the ones that have to make sure
that the messaging is on point that
people get what we want to say that
we're saying the right things to the
right people at the right time
that you know if there's a massive
change happening in the market then
we're able to react to it in a way
that makes us part of the news cycle
like all of that is
very very stressful to some people but
for communications people we thrive on
and it's just like best day ever i
worked a 12-hour day and it felt like
two hours
by like that it's like ah amazing i love
it
danielle thank you so much for coming
here i really i had a great time
hey three short questions are you ready
yes okay favorite subject in school
k-12 inc english
okay i see the connection yeah
one one of your role models or somebody
that you
as you look up to you get inspired by
my mother yeah my mother is
a very very strong
career woman with a very strong track
record if people google my first last
name then you'll find her she works for
a small company called microsoft you
might have heard of it
wonderful and last question three words
that you would use to describe yourself
strong ambitious and weird
strong ambitious and weird i love that
why why
the weird part tell me a little bit
about that
i think everyone worth talking to is a
little weird
people that are normal or a little
boring and i'm and and it's just like
i i get that feedback from a lot of
people from france for my husband for my
family i think i'm weird but in a good
way i'm weird in a way that keeps me
interesting that people are like
ha okay so i kind of
i like that i think that's something
that sets me apart it's something that
people
um you know i i at least it seems find a
little bit entertaining but not in a way
that they're laughing
at me but they're laughing with me so
that's like a good thing i think i have
going for me
right we don't have much time but i do i
don't want to ask one more question that
i wanted to ask before
if you were to go back to your time with
stand with us as an intern
would you would this be the career that
you would expect yourself to be at
or this trajectory or are you surprised
by it
i would probably be surprised by it when
i was interning for stan with hopes i
still
thought i thought that the way in which
i would change the world was very
specific
and i think what i learned is that there
are a lot of ways to change the world
and as long as you're making
a positive impact and you put passion
into what you do it sounds cheesy but
it's true
having a positive impact on people is
how you change the world
um so i'm not maybe like actively
working towards
world peace and all that stuff that i
thought i was going to be doing when i
was younger but
changing the world doing good important
work and doing it
while making people happy and making
them smile
small steps daniel thank you so so much
and
thank you for coming here stay safe and
stay healthy and best of luck with
everything you're doing with after flyer
it looks amazing
thank you michael it's been a pleasure
bye-bye
[Music]
bye